one of the things that you've already
recognized is that mathematical
induction can be used for all kinds of
different things it's not like when you
did geometry proofs and then you learned
about you learnt about congruence and
all the different tests to do with that
but that's all you could prove with
those tests they were just betraying or
congruence right mathematical induction
is kind of like a it's like a Swiss Army
knife if you guys know born in this
exact it's got you pull it out and
there's all these little bits pointing
out of it and it can do almost anything
if you know how to wield the tool
appropriately so we're going to look at
these things called divisibility proofs
we haven't thought about divisibility
since well you seven I'd probably say
maybe maybe you right if you do learn it
successfully seven that you had to
review it so what does it mean to say
that a number is divisible for instance
if I say 42 is divisible by seven what
does that actually mean what does that
statement mean any takers
like come on we've seen this statement
before how would you explain it to
someone who's never heard of this word
divisible what you reckon William what
would you how would you explain what
that sentence means to someone's never
had it before yeah okay so wait hold on
a second let's rewind
what's William talking about splitting
what is he splitting up you he's
splitting forty-two right hits the word
like divisible has the word divided in
it clearly okay forty-two can be split
in two it's it can be flipped split it
into seven times six do you agree with
that now it's worth noting that you can
split any number into two different
components multiplication right I could
say for example forty is uh well it's
seven times forty on seven and that's
still true isn't it but why isn't that
divisible by seven because last I
checked forty is not divisible by seven
this is a real this a real question you
this this piece of watch is gonna be
really important for doing this proof
later on why is this divisible by seven
words this is not just seven is a whole
number forty on seven is not a whole
number
okay forty-one seven is five and five
sevenths five and five sevenths so this
is not a whole number and that's kind of
what we're after over here okay I guess
another way we could say it is that you
can write 42 as the what do we call it
when you have two numbers multiplied by
each other it start to appear it's the
product right we can write 42 is the
product that's so important I'm gonna
write it down as the product of two
whole numbers so when we want something
to be to visit by something else this is
really what we're going after right the
product of two whole numbers to say it's
divisible by a particular number means
one of those numbers will be that guy
right is that okay so let's have a look
at this this is the way you will see a
question phrase to you in a typical
fashion like at the HSC I'm gonna show
you some of those in a minute but they
have a look at something like this
underline that that part there this
expression because this is not just a
number this could be any number right
based on different values of n this
could be what we're gonna see what kinds
of values it can take on and what we're
positive what we're proposing is that
every single one of them for any value
of n that you'd like that fits this
condition in here which by the way
should ring a bell right so long as we
fit this condition here anything that we
get here will be a multiple of seven
okay which is by the way another way of
saying this as well okay now this though
is different from what you were having a
look at last week would see syriza's
right because when you had something
like that your statement that you were
going to prove well it was an equation
right it was something equals something
and then you started to proven off you
went okay there's no equation here
there's no equation so in a minute we're
going to have to work out an equation to
be able to prove something
I don't have one at the moment but
before we do that we can still begin
some of the steps of induction if you
remember there were three main steps
what was the first one what was the
first one said Gary okay so so I'm going
to test whether the first value of n
actually works okay so before I actually
write this down I'm going to suggest you
know usually you don't have the
handwritten version of your own question
you know above we're about to write out
your question this is just printed for
you right so I think it's nice to get
into the habit of saying required to
prove so you don't write this as a as an
actual statement as if it's already true
and you can put in a somewhat
abbreviated form if you like so I'm
going to say that that is that's it is
is divisible by four and you might
remember mrs. Lee's introduced to you
some really nice concise set notation
which allows us to say this but in a lot
fewer symbols do you remember the way
that she wrote it for M and then there
was a a weird Greek symbol that's an
epsilon right which means M belongs to
or is an element in this guy the set of
all positive integers do you remember
how to write that what was the symbol it
was like a weird funky Zed like that
which stands for the German words R
which just means count as in counting
numbers so those are the integers there
we worked not just any integers then we
want positive integers so how do we
indicate that remember we put that
little plus there okay cool so this is
exactly the same as that now our first
step is to test okay now in so many
cases you get asked for all positive
integers and so you're getting the habit
of saying that the first value and you
can test is N equals 1 okay it's worth
noting though and you probably seem to
be able in your series already actually
know maybe they haven't I forgot to look
through the examples that you guys got
given before this is not always where
you begin definitely some of the ones
I'm going to give you too
they don't start at N equals one they
might start at four or 11 or a hundred
you just have to watch out for whichever
ones which okay let's have a look so
when N equals one I can say 5 to the 1
plus 3 and here like we have to actually
show that this is the case even though
the numbers are so small you can look at
and say oh obviously right but it's not
obvious that's why we're proving it so
I'm going to go ahead and I'm putting
all the working there now that's 8 now
again we know that 8 is a small enough
number that we're like that's definitely
divisible by 4 but think back to what we
were talking about about what it means
for a number to be divisible by
something else what's something I could
write after here that would say without
a shadow of a doubt for someone who
maybe doesn't know they're 4 times
tables up to the second half of you what
would be a proof beyond a shadow of a
doubt that that number is divisible by 4
yeah I'm gonna write it as the product
of two whole numbers where one of them
is 4 so 2 times 4 will do just fine okay
are you happy with that so if I can
establish that it's 4 times some other
whole number BAM
up there okay so therefore it's true for
my chosen value okay step one was the
test
what would step two this is kind of a
really important step in induction yeah
very good so I'm gonna go a little
further than that I'm not going to
assume that N equals K because he and
you got it like there's so many pretty
rules and things flying around assume N
equals K is missing some logic in there
what I mean is I'm going to assume that
a statement a particular statement is
true for N equals K really subtle
distinction if I were to assume that N
equals K that would mean that and which
over here is a variable you see it can
change it can be any positive integer I
like if I assume that N equals K then
that would mean this guy can only take
on one particular value namely K
whatever I want that to be but that's
not actually what I'm assuming
assuming that n can change right but
that when n is K at that particular time
it will make my statement true okay now
at this point I don't really want to
write out this whole thing and then say
okay right for a particular into
positive integer okay I want to form
this into an equation so that I can
manipulate it okay and if you have a
look on the board again we've got the
clues we need to write an equation
that's equivalent to this sentence okay
so let's begin by putting in this sum
this K into where it belongs so 5 to the
k plus 3 right it's the beginning of the
statement now if this thing whatever
this number happens to be really is
divisible by 4 then just like with 42
for this or just like eight I should be
able to say that this number is equal to
the product of two whole numbers where
one of them is four right does that make
sense and if it's divisible by some
other number like 11 or 18 or something
like that then I would have that here
well I don't know what the other part of
the number is it's four times well I
don't know because I don't know what K
is I don't know if it's 2 or 6 or
something like that so I need to
introduce a new pronumeral here I know
I've already got a few but I don't know
what this thing is so I don't have a
choice
I have to put in your 1 in some people
like to put capital n for number the
fact that we've got another n over here
makes me kind of reluctant to do that so
I'm gonna use the letter P capital P I'm
gonna use a Q later on as well you can
use anything you'd like you can use X
etc but if you have a convention and you
can follow it that way you would get too
confused now stop for a moment and once
you've written that this statement
doesn't yet mean this statement here I
should say doesn't yet mean that 5 to
the k plus 3 is divisible by 4 even
though it's written as 4 times something
else because again look on the board you
could write that anything is 4 times
something else and that doesn't make it
divisible I could say 42 is 4 times
twenty-one on to ten and a half four
times ten and a half is that but that
doesn't make it divisible by four so I
actually need to provide some extra
information here what would make this
divisible by four P has to be a
particular kind of it just can't be
anything it has to be a whole number a
positive whole number as well so I need
to actually say something about P
thankfully I've got language for this
right so I'm going to say where P is
also a positive integer you care with
that now I will just put it over here
say if you didn't write that down would
you be penalized for that maybe I don't
know because there's a lot of other
stuff like we haven't even begin the the
most important step here where most of
the work is so this is almost sort of
minor thought on the side but I think
it's important because it's part of the
logic by which this functions P can't be
anything it has to be a particular kind
of number